ja hallo ich bin Nico semsrott und
ich bin demotivationstrainer ich
habe als demotivationstrainer auch
eine Geschäftsidee unglückskekse
verkauft die im Anschluss an meine Shows die
Einnahmen gehen zugunsten Alleinerziehender Kinder
für Sprüche drin gucken wir mal nach
möge dein Leben eines Tages so schön
sein wie du es auf Facebook darstellst
ja ich habe eine putzig positive PowerPoint
Präsentation vorbereitet ja Thema wie immer
Depressionen ist natürlich ein bisschen
heikel für so eine Unterhaltungssendung ne
wir merken schon gleich die Stimmung ist
im Keller ja wie machen wir jetzt weiter
ein Kaninchen das war knapp ja ich habe
mehrere Themen vorbereitet Frauen und
Männer und Katzen Drogen Geschichten süßes
Kaninchen Politik oder Entscheidung ich
denke wir nehmen Entscheidungen ja
jeden Tag müssen wir Millionen von
Entscheidungen treffen jeden Morgen schon
die wichtigste Aufstehen oder liegen bleiben
große Frage dann gibt es ein paar
leichtere Fragen ne Kaffee oder
Tee S-Bahn oder Fahrrad und dann wird
schon wieder schwieriger welchem Handy
Anbieter gebe ich meine Daten Apple
Google oder Microsoft ne immer auch
NSA das ist ein ja das ist ein das ist ein
Add-on das ist erst neulich dazu gekommen
Überstunden oder gefeuert werden
das eine freie Wahl oder auch Glück
durch Selbstbetrug oder Unglück durch Realismus
süßes Kätzchen oder süßes Kaninchen das ist
einfach ja es wäre schön wenn in meinem Leben
alle Entscheidungen so einfach werden eine zwei
klare Alternativen das blöde ist in meinem Leben
ist alles viel kompliziert da fangen wir an mit
der wichtigsten Entscheidung im Kapitalismus die
Wahrheit ist Berufs sie entscheidet über Status
und das wiederum über Glück Lebenserwartung
Gesundheit eigentlich alles andere Berufswahl
also eine Entscheidung die man nicht verkacken
sollte ja welche Berufe gibt's so Auswahl zum
Beispiel kann man Lehrer werden oder Putzmann
oder Formel 1 Rennfahrer oder Ballerina es
gibt echt unendlich viele Möglichkeiten ne
bis zur Geburt ja dann wird schon
deutlich weniger die Gene beschränken
die Möglichkeiten ich weiß dass am besten
ich wollte eigentlich Ballerina werden
ja nach dem Ende der Grundschule sind es
dann schon weniger Optionen nach dem Ende
der Schule noch weniger Option dann
nimmt man Beruf und dann ist man tot
ne es geht wirklich ziemlich schnell im Prinzip
ist das bei allen anderen großen Entscheidungen
die man im Leben treffen muss genauso ne bei
Beziehung ist es auch so da haben wir alle sieben
Milliarden Möglichkeiten eine Beziehung einzugehen
wenn man sich auf die Spezies Mensch beschränkt
ist klar ne wenn man dann auch noch Tiere
und Objekte mal rein nimmt dann wird es
unübersichtlich auch mit mit sieben
Milliarden kann man umgehen ja wenn
man dann ja zu einem Menschen sagt sagt man
ja auch automatisch Nein zu allen anderen
eigentlich eine ziemlich brutale Entscheidung
wenn man wenn man sich das mal klar macht
ist eigentlich jede Hochzeit auch die
Scheidung von 7 Milliarden anderen Menschen
riskant ja welche welche Entscheidungen
bereue ich am Ende meines Lebens setze
die man auf dem Sterbebett eher selten
hört hätte ich doch mehr Zeit im Büro
verbracht oder auch hätte ich bei der
Berufswahl doch auf meine Eltern gehört
Sätze die man auf dem Sterbebett auch
eher selten hört habe ich eigentlich den
Herd ausgeschaltet wenn man als Angehöriger
diesen Satz hört dann denkt man auch er hä
stirb ja und wir beenden den ganzen
Vortrag noch mit einem unglückskeks Spruch
wer früh aufgibt kann anderen
beim verlieren zugucken [Applaus]
ach so abonnieren Sie diesen
Kanal dann wird's lustig